hi strange loop I'm super excited to be
here and talk to you about voice driven
development or what it means to write
software using your voice and before I
get into the talk I want to give you a
quick caveat that this entire talk was
created using my voice and it will be
delivered using my voice as well so yeah
brought to you by my voice go next and
Who am I my name is Emily I'm a software
engineer I work or you can find me on
github as touche and on Twitter as Emily
I work at fastly go next and fastly we
help get most important we're a dead
cloud platform that helps the world's
most important digital businesses and
generally what that means is we help
make the internet more reliable faster
and more secure and we are hiring so if
any of this sounds interesting to you
find me and somewhere in the conference
go next I write code mostly Perl using
my voice go next why right why would I
do that go next and the reason is I was
unfortunate enough to start struggling
with some repetitive strain injury a
couple years ago and if you're not
familiar RSI is pain felt in your
muscles nerves and tendons caused by
repetitive and overuse in our industry
that often means repetitive overuse of a
keyboard or a mouse and just out of
curiosity if you're willing to share I
want to see in this room how many people
have either experienced RSI or know
someone who has experienced RSI raise
your hand yeah so this is like a good
majority of the room go next so first
when I was injured I tried taking breaks
from typing I tried yoga stretching I
wore the wrist braces
I tried massage acupuncture chiropractor
go next
I tried pain creams anti-inflammatory 'z
muscle relaxers I went through rounds of
occupational and physical therapies
I even got trigger point injections were
which were as much fun as they sound go
next I had an ergonomic evaluation which
is where you have this fancy orgo
evaluator come to your work
and tell you that everything needs to be
90 degrees and you should maybe stand
desk and you should have a split
keyboard and like all this stuff so did
all that got the split keyboard to
trackball my so I could split the load
right hand left hand go next I got to
know all the specialty keyboards on the
market and eventually ended up with the
mitosis in the top left which is they
grew by keyboard so it's really hard to
replace anything goes wrong and mainly
with that was I tried to reduce the load
up from my pinkies onto my thumbs and
with all those modifications that did
give me a lot it did help significantly
but I was still feeling very frustrated
go next I was still in a lot of pain I
went from you know and it's worse I got
tight maybe 30 minutes a day and maybe I
shouldn't have even been doing that to
maybe 30 to 40 minutes if I took long
breaks in between and I'm taking 4 leave
a day and I'm doing some crazy like
stretching routine and even the time
where I was working wasn't good quality
I was constantly being interrupted by my
body painting your body is like an alert
system firing all the time that is very
distracting as you're working so in
general it was just like a bad time go
next so I started getting some thoughts
about you know well what if I could just
say things instead and remove my hand
from the equation what about this voice
stuff I saw talk you know in 2013 from
this guy who like did it maybe I could
go next so I started looking into it and
what I was expecting
especially writing Perl I was expecting
doing that by voice to go something like
this go next video play open open
parentheses go to beginning a document
to reach oh oh
put an end of that press caps-lock
info you didn't tell press caps lock
press caps lock in the foe believe info
press capital i read i press capital i
delete i press capital i it's ro
press caps lock
delete i scroll this conflict don't
scroll as public delete adult installs
conflict for delete adult scrolls
conflict floor delete adults draws
conflict for open paranthesis felassan
string comma dollar sign times closed
parentheses equals ax inputs semicolon
directs the goals as important equal
sign at input semicolon
equal sign outside input semicolon 1
okay that's better tricks trained one
okay
print dollar sign string X dollar sign x
crutch print print print Brent
prints do okay
x times X 9 okay lowercase and the X
semicolon enter go next
so that whole event that video I
actually trimmed it for the purposes of
this talk the whole video is like 10
minutes long so if you want more of that
there is more you can go find out in
YouTube the guy that made it has screen
8 or his user is scrub it up 1 so look
for that so when I started looking into
the voice coding software that was out
there what I found was much different
than what I was expecting so I'm gonna
show you a clip of me writing the same
code that scrub a dub 1 was writing
except using my tool set that I I use on
a day-to-day and I intentionally left a
few mistakes in it so that you can see
that like editing is is efficient as
well go next video play base quote -
push semicolon enter outside phrase
input op equals OP input all caps info
push semicolon enter phrase close args
all caps input Bush semicolon enter our
stellar free string comma space dollar
phrase times push up equals snip line
Brin dollar phrase string comma space
dollar phrase times push up equals
outside for his input semicolon go up go
left 2nd delete word all caps info go
down [ __ ] brace print space dollar for a
string Perl time Staller for each times
semicolon
go next okay so there's a little bit
different right maybe this is doable so
how how does all that work what
technology goes into me writing a
snippet of code like that I'm gonna dig
into that a little bit go next the tech
I'm using I've got a microphone I'm
really excited about my new fancy mic
these are really cool a good microphone
makes a big difference
using your built-in microphone on your
Mac just isn't going to give you the
kind of accuracy that you want so my
good microphone is key I'm running dead
dragon dictation on my Mac Dragon
Dictation has been around for decades
people generally use it for writing
documents emails you know generally like
spoken word I'm using that for now right
now that's just the voice engine piece
and the technology I'm really excited to
tell everyone about today is Talon Talon
is where a lot of the magic comes for
what I'm doing go next okay so what is
Talon Talon is a hands-free software it
runs on your Mac although there's
working on support for Linux and Windows
currently it works with a voice engine
right now it's running on top of dragon
but the author of Talon is very excited
because we he's working on a new
open-source voice engine based on a wave
to letter that we'll ship soon with the
town beta and it's trained on 3000 hours
of audio and it's very fast is what he's
saying so I'm very excited about that
especially because dragon for Mac has
been discontinued and I'd really like to
stop having to point people to eBay to
find copies of it so really excited
about that but so more about Talon its
programmatically configured with Python
so all of the commands that you see are
not just like baked into talent itself
there are things that are configured in
Python scripts running on my laptop so
it's highly configurable you can map
voice command to this Python function
right so really powerful stuff it's also
free all the talent software's free the
author has been working on it full time
for two years now and he's an RSI
sufferer himself and he's committed to
making this technology available for
people who need it so if you are a kind
soul and want to support the project or
support my
self this patreon is a great way to do
that go next so let's start with the
ABCs or the asdf how do you actually
start typing keys in the keyboard go
next so if you start with the letter
keys you think you might say a and get a
or B get B right but there's a problem
with that a lot of the letters in the
alphabet as pronounced sound very
similar to each other so a hjk b c d EG
p t VZ all sound very close and I'm sure
everyone here has been on a phone call
where you've had to say M is in Mike or
n is Nancy or I is an ice cream or
something silly because it's it's really
hard to spell a word and and have it
clearly understood so I don't want that
kind of trouble
with my my voice dictation that I'm
gonna have to be correcting myself all
the time go next
so the solution is to pick a set of
words that are phonetically different
enough from each other that they're not
going to be confused the there is an
alphabet like this that exists already
the NATO phonetic alphabet and this is a
common question we get why not use the
phonetic alphabet and the reason is not
because of accuracy but because of speed
a lot of these words except for golf are
more than one syllable so I don't want
to say November over and over again
right like nah so we design our own
alphabet go next this is the alphabet I
use it's mostly based on an alphabet
that was put together by the author of
Tallinn who spent a lot of time finding
words that wouldn't be confused with
each other each of the words are like
one syllable very very short and they
don't get confused with each other or
other common commands that we use on a
day to day so that is my alphabet go
next okay so we have arrived at the
scary part of this whole thing live demo
you know so but we're in it together so
we'll see how this goes I'm gonna demo a
few things for you spelling some words
I'm going to show you numbers and
symbols I'm also going to show you how I
get words and phrases and how I use some
special formatters so that I can get the
text formatted like I want Talon demo
harp each look look odd space whale odd
read looked at dip enter one two three
enter pound dollar down score bang bang
/ n R / n bracket our bracket down score
percent enter phrase hello strange loop
enter kebab strange loop oops
enter enter kebab strange loop doesn't
like that let me just check something
here enter enter kebab strange loop
enter all caps strange loop enter pack
titled strange loop enter kebab title
strange loop yeah enter kebab title
strange loop enter talent sleep so I
will say that this is not my normal
acoustic environment so I expect that
you know things are probably a little
less accurate than then I would at home
but so far not too too much of a
disaster so let's continue I'm in a demo
for you some Homa phones so these are
words that sound the same but they're
actually spelled different how does my
system know which word I mean so I'm
going to show you how I disambiguate
those I'm going to show you repetition
so in the video with scrub it up one you
might have seen that you know talent
sleep sorry I had to put the voice robot
to sleep again
so repetition so you if you heard scrub
it up one say backspace backspace you
know over and over again that can get
very annoying so we need a way to like
repeat commands I want to do this thing
but this many times so I'll show you
repeats and I'll also demo for you some
custom vocabulary that these are words
that were not included by default in my
voice engine but I need to add them and
Talon gives me a nice way to do that if
the voice engine can accurately enough
guess what the pronunciation is then
can just add them and they'll just work
so I'll show you a few of those words
Talon mode enter phrase Colonel select
word phones enter phones bite pic 3
enter emoji monocle emoji monocle 10
enter enter emoji whale 4th
delete third enter phrase up cert enter
phrase on deaf enter phrase mojolicious
enter phrase pearl tidy enter phrase
fastly enter phrase Spotify enter
Thailand sleep oh and I forgot to
mention let me just make sure it heard
me
yeah ok cool that the Boop oh gosh I
hate when I do that oh no there's where
it happens where is the oh god hold on
oh gosh
we almost made it through and no
problems okay so I'm gonna mention that
the the repetition I use ordinal numbers
so it sounds a bit like go down 4th
Street right but for me I wanted a way
to represent repeats that I already knew
the rules up to however long I needed to
and I don't know what comes after once
twice thrice so I use ordinals which is
maybe a bit unexpected go next okay so
let's take what we just learned expand
it and see what it's like for me on a
day to day when I'm writing code in my
text editor I'm you using get I am
pushing code to github and you know you
can see a little bit more about how it
all comes together and caveat on this
one I had people ask me if I sped up the
video no this is just the normal speed
also there's no edits it's just me
clicking record and end it is more
rehearse than probably the code I write
on a day to day but this demo isn't
about like showing you how fast I say
things it's more about showing you what
the tool can do so go next video play
see detail and Emily get checkout new
snake emoji search enter subl enter
divvy up go file phrase emoji enter the
page spring one eight push delete start
tab double quote phrase emoji search
space dragon words push colon space for
a search comma spring one for slot slap
state Def phrase search friend mad push
: slap phrase name up equals snake
extract word paren mad slide phrase
emoji Sun up equals snake selection
picker undo phrase set / n square snake
emoji names square price key go right
dot phrase char go right go left space
for
in praise key go right forth snake emoji
names dot phrase keys paren go right
space phrase if name in key slap undo
stone delete word phrase name in space
slap pop jump snake selection picker
arks phrase title equals dub quote title
emoji smear go left son smear comma
space phrase template equals double
quote phrase picker dot harp trap mad
look smear comma space phrase data
equals phrase emoji Sun jumpstart spring
3 slap from import dot phrase utils push
snake extract word slap from import dot
phrase picker push snake selection
picker go down push comma space snake
emoji short names delete word snake
emoji short names space phrase add space
snake emoji names save go file phrase
picker enter spring three slap in
bracket in % pad phrase for item in data
enter tag table row undo slap tag table
row tag class count enter tag table data
take class pick undo undo tag class pick
title pick space slot tag table data in
bracket second pad phrase item go down
slap in bracket in % space each near dip
for odd red space save emoji search moon
cancel
spring six jump forth emoji search sound
pick two space save emoji search dog
emoji search tree cancel focus I turn
run git status get add dot enter run git
commit sit praise add space
delete delete dip-dip space phrase emoji
searching escape : whale quench enter
git push origin phrase emoji tab enter
focus from new window open tallinn
configs link air mad
tap-tap-tap go down third enter link son
mad escape page link dip all right
that's the end of it
[Applause]
so everyone seems to always giggle with
the wail quench and when I first gave
this Tech Talk internally I had to
welcome everyone just like welcome on
each there were welcome oh geez later
and then I took it out from I give a
similar talk to this earlier this year
and I took out the well quench and
people were so mad so I put it back in
the demos so it's their go next and at
the end I have stickers so if this makes
you laugh come see our sticker fairies
down here they'll help you out go next
I'm gonna pivot and talk a little bit
about the challenges of working by voice
go next
but don't worry I'll give you a few tips
to deal with them go next the learning
curve it's a little bit steep we are so
used to touch based models keyboards and
mice it's it's a completely different
part of your body you're using it can be
a little bit like of a learning curve to
get started also it's pretty new in the
space there's some conventions starting
to form but in general most of us have
like a bespoke set up where we've kind
of glob some scripts together written
some ourself hopefully over time you
start to become a little bit more
standardized and there's more tools that
are built to help you learn and all that
but it still is a little bit steep go
next but some tips make sure you set
aside some dedicated learning time so
what I did is I set aside a couple weeks
just I just want to focus on this and
that's it I'm not gonna you know write
any code that's gonna be shipped
anywhere I'm just gonna dedicate my time
to learning I picked some code in my
code base that was gonna be pretty
similar to what I'd be writing and I
just tried copying it and that was a
really great way for me to try it and
then iterate on my talent setup and then
you know keep going until I felt like I
had some sort of like efficiency one
thing that's really difficult is if
you're injured and you're trying to
learn this stuff
it requires typing to learn it but
you're trying to learn it so you don't
have to type and it's kind of a chicken
and egg problem if you have some friends
that don't mind pairing on this with you
to be your hands for this part of it I
recommend that I don't generally
otherwise recommend that you should try
to get people to type for you if you're
injured
I don't know I have opinions about that
but for this in particular yes finding
friends to help pair with remove time
pressures so what I mean by that is
don't take on a bigger factor while
you're trying to also learn to voice
code
you're gonna underestimate how much time
you spend thinking while you're working
and you're probably going to miss a lot
of stuff because you're instead of
focused on your code you're focused on
inputting the code so take easy tickets
take things that aren't time sensitive
also communication with your team work
with your team to make sure that any
communication that doesn't have to
happen in real time and slack in a long
scroll you know move it to the github PR
move it to the JIRA ticket instead so
that you are in a position where you
either have to reach for a keyboard or
you're left behind the conversation
my team has has been very supportive of
all of this so thank you to my wonderful
team out there also leverage the town
community there are there are other
people like me I'm not the only one home
that are we all hang out in the town
slack we're happy to help and share our
scripts and everything so go next Tools
of poor accessibility so this is
probably my biggest challenge right now
most of the time when I have trouble
using a thing with voice it's not
because of my tool set or my setup it's
most often the most frustrating things
are when I'm working on a tool or a
website that was not built with
accessibility guidelines and those are
things that I can't fix myself and I
have to spend a lot of time trying to
work around and it puts me in a really
awkward situations like I have some
right now where our team relies on tools
that I cannot use without a keyboard or
Mouse and I have to either like I don't
know
go plead to the company and be like hey
can you really like pretty hard times
this you know or you know do I make the
entire team we have to shift to a whole
nother thing just because of me like
it's not great
so go next I have some requests for you
all that you should make accessibility a
priority don't lock out users from using
whatever you're building make follow
accessibility guidelines there's a lot
of great resources
there are there's some really great
talks at this conference even so educate
yourselves it really shouldn't be the
afterthought build your software as if
you might need it someday because I
certainly didn't expect to be here I
don't want to be ominous but but maybe
I'm being ominous um I didn't expect to
be here and you know you don't know what
is ahead of you in the future and build
the tools as if you that you would want
if you were in a situation of needing
those accessibility features so go next
voice drain so what happens if you talk
to your computer for eight hours a day
you might put some strain on your vocal
cords go next but there are ways to help
with that stay hydrated you notice I
have my water up here if you are working
in a dry climate you might get a
humidifier that helps I have one at home
don't whisper and don't shout so it
turns out shouting is kind of obvious
but whispering is more of a strain on
your voice than talking at a normal
normal tone some people will get voice
coaches so you hire someone much like
singers or what not have voice coaches
to teach them how to use their
instrument and keep it healthy and get
you'll your wear on it that's also an
option go next go next open offices so
I'm not here to add to the pile of
opinions about whether open offices are
good or bad but adding a microphone is a
little bit of a challenge there are
solutions though so I'm going to walk
you through a few go next a steno mask
so I did not know these existed and
every picture I found of these was
interesting
haha but they're very like they're very
useful and people like me and and other
voice coding folks find them really
useful they are good for dealing with
background noise and giving you privacy
in what you're what you're saying
so for open offices you might get some
people going what are you doing but you
know they do work and they do really
work really well these are actually the
marketing pictures for for these as well
so go next
acoustic pods so I know at least one
person whose company bought him a fancy
glass cube that he gets to work in with
like soundproofing and everything that's
very cool so this is another option if
you know your company has some money to
to buy you a cube go next
remote work so I do have an office or I
do have a desk in our office and I go in
sometimes I've got a little space sort
of off to the side some of my peers have
called it the place where you might put
a Xerox machine but it works for me
otherwise I'm at home because when I'm
at home
turns out it's better for me actually to
be away from my keyboard so don't try
and touch it so I'm on the floor I'm
laying on pillows I might be like you
know - playing software from you know
worried or to yoga pose you know
whatever so yeah I thank you fastly for
being so great with remote workers go
next not so big challenges these are
things that I thought would be hard but
they actually aren't so supporting
specific programming languages I thought
I need to build up like a whole library
stuff just for Perl or a whole library
you know for go or whatever but it turns
out if I want to write go tomorrow I can
just start writing go of course there
would be things that I find that I might
want to optimize but they're just
optimizations there's nothing like I
have to spend a bunch of time to build
up support just to like start using
another language the other one is
building tools of talent so this has
been surprisingly fun and like easy I've
built a lot of my own tools myself and
they're like quick easy wins and I've
built anything from just like shortcuts
for certain key commands to entire web
views that will pop up to show me what
commands do I have forget or what
commands do I have for you know
this other thing so it's really powerful
and you just save it to your talent
directory and it's loaded in talent and
ready to go that's pretty great go next
okay so why I want to revisit why I'm
here
why I'm doing all of this why am I
talking to my computer why am I here
telling you about it and I want to
remind everyone that you know this isn't
just some like weird software that's
like funny to you know hear and and
interesting it's literally what gives me
access to my career and to my computer
think about what it would be like if
tomorrow you lost access to your
computer how much of your life is like
in that device right so this is what
gives people like me or people who are
otherwise unable to use a keyboard or
mouse access so it's very important go
next alright some takeaways take care of
your bodies get that order evaluation
appreciate what it can do for you today
they're pretty amazing instruments after
all I hope that by now you will be
convinced that there are people using
speech to code in real life we do exist
there's a small community of us it's not
just me it wasn't you know it wasn't the
first one and and there there's a group
of us consider all your users when
building and designing if there's one
takeaway I want you to have is this one
please Heath this is my plea consider
all your users been building and
designing and if there's one like sort
of thought leader moment I'm gonna have
it's that I think the future is gonna be
a little bit more diverse than the
keyboard mouse touch models that we've
we've been having with you're seeing
this a little bit with voice assistance
coming into popularity and home
automation Alexis Siri you're seeing
voice coding and you're also seeing some
work not on voice but other companies
that are having like wearables that are
gonna you know read your neurological
signals and let you control a computer
so the touch board they're sorry the
touch based model of controlling your
computer might not be the default going
forward at some point so I think it's
worth keeping that in mind and watching
the spaces I think it'll be interesting
go next thank you go next
[Applause]
so next last slide I'm gonna do some
questions but first go next I did by yes
I did by the whale quench club domain um
and dock club is very cheap turns out um
so if you want more information I just
put together some blog post with you
know beginner tutorials things like that
you can find out there also talent voice
calm is where you can find resources on
talent and the talents black and all
that so I'll take your questions and
then don't forget at the end stickers so
yes question the question was how hard
is it to use it in a key stroke heavy
tool like Emacs or IntelliJ I'm not
familiar with either of those Bella is
Emacs sort of like vim regret that
comment later but um it was so for
amendment for example everything is just
like letter keys right so that's pretty
easy once you know the alphabet you can
get around Finn you just say the
alphabet keys for to do whatever is
equivalent right
oh yeah I forgot to done with that yeah
so modifiers are just control shift okay
you know and you can combine those with
other keys so you can you can say like
command air select all command you know
whatever so you can combine them all or
you can make shortcuts if you don't want
to remember like three different keys
you can make a shortcut it's easier yeah
so the question is what do I do when I
need to select certain things on the
screen or draw specific shapes drawing
shapes that's a little bit more
difficult it depends on what I'm doing
if I drawing like a diagram for like a
design document or something I just
learned the like the dot thing where you
can like write code it'll generate your
things for you that was really cool when
I need to select things on the screen I
use vim iam in the browser and that's my
first go-to because I can you know show
me all the links on the page and then I
can just lit using the alphabet click
whatever I need if that doesn't work
because this site doesn't have the
things that are links as actual links
then I might try the tab method where
I'm going to try tabbing through the
page just see if I can get to the thing
and usually that results in frustration
and you know sadness but but those are
two ways that I try to do that yeah
right yeah so the question was
commenting on the vista video where it
was misunderstanding the delete and
instead writing the word delete and how
do you you know make sure you're getting
the right thing what if you want the
word delete right so the way that we
handle this is the whole thing is
designed to be command based so if I
want actual text then I have to preface
I say a command
that means this is text following this
and so if I want the word delete I say
phrase delete and then that should give
me delete otherwise it's all it all
should not - a command yeah so the
question is whether I can use a keyboard
or mouse at all and or my purely speech
based I use speech as much as possible
I'm still dealing with my injury so as
much as I can get off the keyboard while
I pursue healing and all that is is good
for me there are still times where I
will use a keyboard or mouse for things
some other voice coders will use an eye
tracker device to get the mouse
functionality I tend to like to lay on
the floor and stuff so I don't I've gone
I haven't gone that route but um I still
do reach for the keyboard of mouse every
now and then but I try to keep it very
minimal I'm just like touching a few
thing and then I step away yeah
the question was whether a switch would
be in combination with voice useful
maybe it really depends on your workflow
and what do you would need it for for me
I don't generally like to be standing or
sitting at the desk so I don't want to
have to be near a foot pedal but you
know that's just me the question was if
I fully heal when I go back to the
keyboard and mouse or would I stay boys
at this point there are things that are
easier for me by voice and I'd probably
still reach like there were sometimes if
I'm on the keyboard and then I'm like oh
wait this is way easier with the mic
words of Mike and I get the money you
know so I'm at this point I don't know I
think I probably would keep doing what
I'm doing
the question was it appears I'm becoming
more of a user interface expert and
whether that's shaping my opinions on
whether how things should be built
that's the question right or my career
okay haha so extra might be a strong
word but I'm definitely learning a lot
about you is and how things are built
and how they're used and everything and
I'm trying to learn enough that I can
file bug reports that won't be ignored
so that's that's my goal but I don't
know in terms of where my career is
going I I'm not sure I feel like I'm
just now getting back to being able to
think about that you know I'm just okay
let's get back to my actual normal
programming and being able to do work
and you know be productive and think
about where my career is headed but
certainly I think voice technology will
be at the very least a side project it's
something I'm really passionate about
now and I find it fun so yeah I think
one more do we have time one oh we
should be ending last one where I could
write and ship code it the question was
how long did it take me to be able to
write in ship code and I would say it
took me a few weeks just to get
comfortable in the editor but a lot of
that is because I had to write my own
library for sublime there wasn't one yet
so it would probably be faster for
someone else coming on now
but I definitely think I like ship some
things at least it's within a month or
two it really depended because it took
me a lot longer than maybe it would
someone else who wasn't as severely
injured as I was at the time because if
I only have a couple hours to type a day
that doesn't give me a lot to go off of
in terms of making progress that day you
know so yeah that's it anyway thank you
all for coming thank you for listening
you